welcome back while Teresa may has this
week travel to Brussels and Dublin to
try and renegotiate the Irish backstop
so far seemingly without much luck well
joining us now is the chief secretary to
the Treasury mistress good morning
savoury what's the first time I've
interviewed you on the show so I'm going
to try and find out your brexit red
lines and because this week Jeremy
Corbyn has come set out what could be
seen as a path to a deal through a
permanent customs union is that
something that you could pack well first
of all I do think that jeremy corbyn's
positional brexit is better than Tony
Blair at least he's acknowledging the
referendum happened and that we need to
move forward but fundamentally you know
we need to have an independent trade
policy that's what we set out in our
manifesto that is what we need to be
able to have the freedom to succeed
after brexit so the customs union isn't
the right approach and what we showed
two weeks ago in Parliament is we do
have a way through you know the Brady
amendment got the support of a majority
in parliament it's not gonna get a
support from the EU that's the proper
business I have you a negotiation I
believe it is and we've already seen
movement from the EU they've already
said they're prepared to come back to
the table and talk about the
opportunities well we've got on the
table so the time limit the unilateral
exit mechanism looking at alternative
arrangements and I believe trees have
may can get that deal I mean this is one
element of the withdrawal agreement that
the Conservative Party and others had an
issue with in fact Jeremy Corbyn himself
has said that the backstop is an issue
the EU have indicated that there can be
further discussions we now need to get
that indicator that they're going to
budge on the backs talk at all but
before any negotiation nobody goes in
saying I'm gonna give up all the things
I've previously said they don't say that
but the fact is the EU do want to deal
this is one element they've always said
at the beginning of the negotiations
safety they've always said that the
backstop is a temporary measure now what
we want to do is make sure that's
properly in law that it is either
temporary or we've got a unilateral exit
mechanism and that to me is the way
through that is the pathway to the
future it commands the support of
Conservative MPs it commands
supportive quite a number of Labour MPs
in leave leaning seats and that is the
majority and if you remember a few weeks
ago the EU we're saying there's nothing
that commands majority in the House of
Commons Britain please tell us what you
want we've told them what we want and
now's the time to deliver it and you
know I appreciate Jeremy Corbyn has come
to the table but the reality is what
he's proposing does not deliver on what
we want such as a theory just to be
really clear if it were to become
government policy to pursue a customs
union would you resign it is not
government policy to try you've only
read lines I want an independent trade
policy I think that's incredibly
important so I don't think we would
command the support of parliament could
you see how the policy pursued a perm I
absolutely do not think that should be
our policy okay white the answer to the
question but I do see where you're
coming from now less than 50 days to
brexit if MPs can't reach an agreement
by the end of March do you think there
should be an extension to your article
15 well I believe that MPs will reach an
agreement by the end of March and I
think in any negotiation and any piece
of work as the deadline approaches mines
get focused and a deal gets done and I
think by extending the deadline that
doesn't create any new information all
that does is delay things I think yeah a
very bad idea
are you worried about a noodle break sir
I don't want to know deal breaks it but
we are prepared for it and we will have
to do it if absolutely necessary but I
don't believe it will be necessary and
the best way to avoid a No Deal brexit
is getting the deal the Prime Minister's
laid out that says now I'm keen to get
your comments on an upper story that's
been in the news today about ambhiraj
the working pensioner secretary who has
announced this crack down on bosses who
mismanaged pension schemes can you just
explain what the aim is there for what
this is all about is it's about
organisations like Philip Greene's
organization where there have been
issues with pension schemes being
mismanaged and it's about saying that's
not acceptable it's not acceptable to
they marry hell with the contributions
workers have made over a period of time
and essentially run off without making
good the pensions you've promised to
those people in the future and saying
we'll take further sanctions I mean on
the Philip Green issue I do think it is
disgraceful that he has been able to use
non-disclosure agreements to effectively
silence victims of sexual and racial
abuse and I think we need to look
seriously out those non-disclosure
agreements and get changes to them
because I think it's completely wrong
that people like Philip green have been
able to flout the law okay now this week
your conceptive colleague Christopher
chope blocked some legislation on female
genital mutilation I mean you've been
speaking out about this on Twitter what
went through your mind when you first
saw that that it happened well just
absolutely appalled because we know
there is only been one conviction
against somebody for female genital
mutilation this is an action that harms
the lives of girls this is happening in
our country in the 21st century I find
that appalling and we need to do much
much more to stop it and when I see one
of my colleagues opposing a measure that
could have saved girls lives could have
saved girls from that horrendous
experience
I am absolutely appalled by that are you
shame to be sitting on the same bench
ISM well I'm going to be speaking to him
this week I want to see him change his
mind I want to see the Conservative
Party make sure that we show that that
is completely unacceptable so you say
gonna speak to him this week what if you
ask for meeting what what you know be
doing well I will be looking for him
around the comments because to call him
I well and I think conservatives do need
to put peer pressure on our colleagues
here we're stopping these types of
things happening I think this is a very
very serious issue it's been a serious
issue
in this country for some time girls
lives are at threat and that is
appalling that we weren't able to put
that legislation I know you got the whip
with me I know the the government now
the Chief Whip has said he is going to
find the space to put that through in
government time I think that's very
positive so
we'll take action against against an on
this issue so should happen what remove
do you think I want to change his mind I
think the way you win in politics is by
bringing people over to your point of
view I don't like the kind of
deselection
itis that's going on in the Labour Party
I think it's highly highly destructive
but I do think we need as a Conservative
Party to tackle the real issues of
modern Britain and for female genital
mutilation to go and for those girls to
be under threat and asked not taking
action on it I think is something that
isn't acceptable I mean one of the other
issues of the modern world is social
media it's something that was talking
about with my previous guest Labor's
shadow health secretary so I'm
interested from your perspective because
I know that you're someone who doesn't
really like new laws and legislation
necessarily but do you think there
should be more regulation on social
media companies so I'm a parent of two
daughters one of which has a mobile
phone so I completely understand where
her parents are coming from and I do my
best to you know limit use make sure the
phone has a care for you not use you
know a box is that right I do lock it in
a box at night and you know make sure
those rules but I think all parents get
worried about exactly what might be
happening you can't have 24-hour
surveillance on your children and I do
think that companies have a
responsibility schools have a
responsibility I very pleased by the
announcement last week that we're
seeking to get more schools to ban
mobile phone use in schools but when it
comes to regulation we need to make sure
we get that regulation right because
what can sometimes inadvertently happen
is you end up putting power in the hands
of the big companies the companies were
the big legal departments the companies
that can deal with these issues and we
don't want to be in a position where
social media companies become the
censors where they become the arbiters
of what's right and what's wrong and I
think ultimately yes the government does
need to look at the regulatory landscape
we are about to launch our white paper
on online and we need to look at all of
the bodies we've got at the moment so
we've got a broadcasting standards body
and Advertising Standards Authority and
I think what's changed since we put all
those regulatory bodies in places they
were before we had on
Media and I think that whatever content
it is we need to think about it in a
similar fashion you know it shouldn't
matter whether it's on TV or whether
it's online we need to look at it across
the board it's interesting hearing you
talk about mochi nation there you're
someone who I know often speaks out
about too much regulation not being
using the right way so I just wondered
do you think sometimes that the you know
the modern-day conservative parties
strayed a bit far from its Thatcherite
principles I think sometimes they can we
can end up having quite a lot of micro
regulation but that doesn't mean to say
we don't need really tough regulation in
areas like competition in areas like
unfair practice but sometimes having too
much regulation can actually stop taking
the big decisions that that we need to
take so I'm not against regulation in
principle what I'm saying is we have to
be very very careful that the regulation
that is in place isn't just benefiting
the big players in the market and
actually stopping people enter markets I
meet a lot of small businesses across
the country and what they often say to
me is we have to go through so many
different government bodies we have to
get see many permissions it's actually
really difficult for us to compete with
the big energy companies or the big
mobile phone companies so we've got to
be yes we have to have regulation but we
need to make sure it's simple we need to
make sure it's a transparent and we need
to make sure it benefits the consumer
and not those vested interests you're
already operating in the market no I'm
being told him I hear that we're out of
time but there is one more question I do
what to ask you so I'm just going to
squeeze it in anyway now you gave a
speech on Monday where you talked about
women and so I just want to have a quick
look about what you did say about women
and we brought up to be compliant to
behave yourself well I say no to that I
think we need to be disruptive
are you disruptive what's the most
disruptive thing you've done well I'd
rather than Colerain Chris Evert rape in
the House of Commons well I do try and I
make a conscious decision to try and
speak out because I am at the top table
in government and quite often the can be
pressure to always go along with what
made the party wants or to
not not speak out and do you get man
Spain too sometimes of course yeah and I
think it happens in every walk of life I
used to work in the oil industry I'm
familiar with a practice of mansplaining
and there were quite a lot of people in
my party and others who think they know
best and they think they know more than
you and will like to tell you say and I
think you often have to think what is
the most outrageous thing I could say
and actually decide to say it and I
think don't feel safe you've got
platform Sophie well I what I was trying
to say about women is that too often
girls are taught to be compliant they're
taught to be good they're taught to
behave themselves and actually the most
successful women in days who do things
differently Theresa May with somebody
who spoke out when she made the speech
about the nasty party mrs. Thatcher was
a leader who didn't always take things
lying down and I want to encourage the
next generation of business women in
particular to be prepared to say those
things and take those steps okay let's
trust thank you very much